hi everyone it's Jerry I'm going to
track the final three games of Carlson
in this early title
Tuesday uh January 30th he's currently
on 7 and a half out of eight one perfect
jpim eight out of eight some others Rune
Hans on Twitch bortnik Carana kramnick a
lot of players with seven out of eight
so we'll see what these final few rounds
bring okay here we go round number nine
Carlson with
white I've been catching a handful of
his games from this
event um his last game he started out
the wild Rook Pawn but something more
serious here to be
sure E4 and Knight E2 so still staying
flexible
might go for a G3 setup yeah we do have
that G3 Bishop
G2 there is a bit of a tell there with
Knight E2 could still turn it into an
open Sicilian we do have that I'm having
difficulties drawing an arrow the moves
are coming in just before I'm trying to
draw them in
so always have to watch out for Knight
D5 with this Rook on E1 but not here I
don't
believe Black's just a a move out from
kingside
castles so we're gonna have an ending
here playing against the structure
basically he's going to try and show
that these guys are wonderful oh do you
exchange Queens okay no you don't
initiate it he's okay recapturing with
the
Knight I believe you could have also
initiated and then captured here oh okay
so no Queen exchange here
yeah Knight A4 sensible to focus on the
weak square and also look to kick this
strong piece away
C4 so not quite an ending with the queen
still
on
um Where Do We Go From Here sensible
moves that crossed my mind Queen E2 C4
might see the H Pawn bolt as well trying
to induce some
weakness C4
first Rook may be just all the way back
oh okay you don't even have to react
just yet Tempo against the
queen it's now decision do we want to go
for this kind of
maneuver oh he has an eye maybe on Rook
B3 now there's no Rook B8 Bishop has
that one
covered offer of a queen exchange yet
again
so you got this majority it's not the
easiest majority to create a past Pawn
against these guys that are
split uh one thing I like here is this
Pawn fixed one thing I would like for
white this guy here fixed on a dark
Square so it could be targeted by this
guy so
bad uh good versus bad Bishop
positions can tip in White's
favor yeah very tough
to uh REM move this night really wow
he's welcome to taking on doubled B
pawns that's very
interesting so he's saying that if you
canest the file in the end there's well
this this Pawn would fall straight away
actually exchange Rooks Bishop takes
Knight takes
C5 so slowly improving the king now I
spoke of a majority here for white on
the queen side black has these guys
they're healthy
King's walking a tight rope here towards
the
center
okay these guys are nice and
cozy Black's in a I think pretty decent
position
here better uh White Rook is the only
thing I see here for
white um well this this is the big
difference that sticks out to
me The Rook positions
the Knight is under control pretty well
these forward moves over here C5 has
defended well enough and now black is
poking
around Carlson on the
defensive it was a threat trying to
follow up with the a skewer would not
have been there the bishop could could
have
returned to E5 and defend
G7 I think it's best I just highlight
squares in instead of trying to draw an
arrow like one for one for seven in
trying to draw an arrow here some dark
Square weaknesses in Black's Camp still
a potential Target also King C3 and B4
is going to be away yeah we do have that
now do you try and clamp down on the B4
break is the thing also if this Knight
moves there's a check here okay he's
doing it with the
Rook
you make
progress
H you definitely want to watch out for
this okay so clamping down on this break
this guy's all in on the queen
side um that's interesting me try and
reroute him he's going after this
guy creating a square here first also
staying out of the way of Knight E4 so
we might have this Knight F6 six Bishop
here Knight E4 is no longer hitting with
check I think you have to try and get
this bishop in in the mix here oh
wow wow I did not see this one coming
it's going to walk up to A4 with the
King he's notice he's not so quick to
give up this F6 Square to the Knight but
this Knight is going to find a very good
Square here on C6 and look at how
quickly The Bishop's there to tame this
guy a lot of pressure on the clock here
minute Advantage for
Carlson now forget about the king walk
up to A4 I don't know if you could
really he's he's still going to go for
it I spoke too soon
okay Bishop takes
Knight black is the only side that could
really be better there and the two pawns
B4 C5 would restrict these three only
one base point to watch over after a
takes
B and I feel like black would be able to
get this advance in much more easily
with the minor pieces
off might have repetition or yeah might
go for repetition he's still going to
try could over press and
lose trying trying to squeeze more out
of the position than is really
there so if you try to enter here the
king's going to step right back over the
Knight is not even allowing this idea to
sneak up here is now a moment to maybe
try for
it be very
risky okay he's going for
it he is going for it let's see what
kind of restriction that really places
on black I guess it is going to place
one cuz then Rook here King back you
could start thinking about capturing on
A5 so right here now if King hears The
Rook is not in a spot to play some pin
so The Rook at enter it's going there
first was that a oh it wasn't a mouse
slip that was really his intention so a
Super Active white Rook pressure on the
clock under three seconds
okay wild
Rook some breathing SP he's going to win
this one yeah he's mopping up every pawn
and look at how active this king is in
the end wow king walk up the a file
there that was
beautiful might insert the check so this
and then you're already on this guy
they're all going to fall resignation
whoa that was an awesome game what a
cool idea normally ending you keep the
king in the
center now he found a path in King
putting pressure on the isolated A5 pun
oh what a
game okay here we go go the highly
anticipated matchup here Carlson playing
White against Hans a second white
here E4 no Shenanigans here some serious
chess bringing out the World Chess
Championship prep R
Lopez Berlin land okay no Queen exchange
line though
they're blitzing out the moves here
bulleting out the
moves I didn't comment yet
Carlson's rating is over just a bit over
3,300
here Hans at 3212
so they're trading
machines they're just going to have a
peaceful result no
way Carlson's going to go
for
um they're I think they're going for a
draw
here yeah they're going for a
draw wow peaceful result I think this
was a one of the lines yeah they end up
just locking all the pawns this was one
of the lines with uh Carlson's game
against unand I believe the one time to
take it into tie breaks or something is
he really going to try something there
still is some room over here on the king
side to
maneuver but this should just be a
draw nothing's happening
after yeah definitely after this
everything is locked up we're going to
see a draw offer or maybe some silly
King
moves King back and
forth they're just going to have some
fun here for a bunch of more
moves okay how many pawns could actually
move in this
position 1 2 3 4 that's it but there are
no good Pawn breaks
clearly you're not going to see another
pawn
move maybe at move 50 if they go to that
point they'll have to calculate though
and make sure it's move 50 cuz a pawn
move at this stage and you
lose no three-fold repetition
yet was this the plan all
along some agreement hey if we ever get
paired up again let's just make a draw
go down this line here okay an 87 move
draw probably one of the first games to
finish a peaceful result between the
two okay yeah let's check out that
opening again real
quick they were firing off all of these
moves we ended up with
the symmetrical structure
and yeah just one trade after the other
there's only one open file so that
usually results
in almost all major pieces coming off a
little tactic there based on the fork
Knight F6 yeah there's just no progress
to be made everything is fixed here and
silly King moves to finish 87 mover all
right so we're going to have one more
game Carlson is on nine out of 10 we'll
see his final round game okay Final
Round
Here uh with standings are Carlson has
nine Jeffrey
Jang has
nine
and Carlson's opponent here has nine so
Anton corov
the opponent here noever goes in Bishop
E2 all right isolated Queen
Pawn will most likely be happening
here for one side or the other thinking
it's going to be
for
black or do you keep things symmetrical
you could consider capture on C4 okay so
a symmetrical
structure not as much
play the symmetrical structures
B5 keeping the tension the Queens Bishop
B7 right around the corner where to go
with the light Square Bishop headed for
F3
maybe Rook C1 tactically vulnerable
Bishop on C5 it's covered with the
Knight here Knight also stays out of the
way of the
bishop dark Square Bishop exchange and
queen
here White Queen on D6 Queen B6 a knight
on B6 would be very good I feel in an
ending looking to drive the Knight away
without allowing Knight to
A4 we do have
that also in these positions if if we
have a queen exchange I'd be leaning
towards moving this Rook first so that
the king is can fast track it way
towards the center on
E7 but still keeping the tension with
the Queen
safeguarding the Knight here no B4
push once the Queens are off each side
could think maybe a bit more
aggressively with the pawn play so for
instance you might think about playing
G5 if this Knight is no longer here the
weaknesses aren't going to be exploited
in an ending like this the Knight has an
ion
B3 um who is better if any
side don't really know I
mean if we strip it down to just the
pawns here there's a higher quality B
Pawn compared to B2 B5 versus
B2
um I don't know how else to really look
at it the king getting to E6 that's a
comfortable square a dark Square this
guy's not going to bother
him so trying to get at the C2 Square
now that there's no longer a C3
Knight first things first though got to
defend the bishop Rook C7 comes to mind
this guy's
unprotected Rook there would run into
that
one then you still have to sort out the
problem on B7 so Rook C7 it
is
any fancy Knight moves Bishop F3 could
be right around the
corner watch out for back ranked
mates Knight could be
kicked where you could think about
Bishop
F3 with Rook takes Bishop as an idea
Knight A4 watch out this Rook is a kind
of short on squares only has these two
Knight A4 Fork B2 and The Rook
not too much of a time
difference very jumpy
Knight where to go exactly if we go here
then I mean C3 is weak oh did not see
that one
coming so how's this playing out
exactly yeah he's still able to land
that one Knight A4 Knight takes Rook
Knight takes
Rook should not be enough I'm not so and
also the pause here by white is making
me think he overlooked this idea that
black didn't have to react to this
threat right
away yeah no back ranked mate The Rook
is
pinned important detail there if the
King was on F2 this move is a blunder
Rook
C1 Rook d8 leading to
mate now the king gets to sneak on over
so two pieces our two pawns versus the
peace versus the
bishop not
enough exchange Rooks and then put the
king here you could enter first as well
why not establish a strong Rook position
and then King
E7 covering all Invasion
points okay King there
first really not sure why that isn't in
cted first Rook
C2 H don't
know okay oh maybe in the end he wants
Rook C3 Rook C3 on
board wants to drive the night away
wants to cover this one possible Target
okay he's focused right on the weak
squares no rush notice with taking that
pawn you probably could would have but I
think there's some concern about The
Rook gaining some activity if you go
after the a pawn
so kind of wants it
all he's he's not being materialistic is
what I should be saying peace
improvements first tracks that guy down
these guys are looking a bit scary
though must
admit Rook is under Fire pressure on the
clock 30 second Advantage for the doctor
the
doctor uh
can't get that out of my head from his
Dr drunkenstein
account
Lees so you could end up sacking a piece
back for these two maybe he's going for
that does he have time for
this he's saying yeah I do have time for
this I mean is he is he going to be able
to weave a mate with these
three what if they just keep
pushing um has he really worked out
these DET okay he has to oh the bishop
could come
back the bishop is there in time okay so
it's two minor pieces versus these two
we might have
resignation yeah it's time to resign at
this
stage for some reason I wasn't seeing
that the bishop could take a step back
and be there just in the nick of time to
stop
promotion so that's a winner let's see
if he ends up actually taking the top
spot
all right there it is top three Carlson
taking first 10 out of 11 Jeffrey Jong n
and a half out of 11 and then Hans
Neeman N9 out of 11 there were actually
10 players with nine out of 11 but Hans
got that one on tie
breaks anyhow Feel Free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care
bye